Vendors become certified through
a formal testing process developed by
the National Institute of Standards and
Technology, or NIST for short.
The actual testing is administered
by one of several companies who have
contracted with NIST to do it.
We'll now take a closer look at that
using one of the required items for
data collection.
You should recall that a certified EHR
must maintain a current problem list.
But what does that mean?
Medical problems are usually coded
in a global data standard called
the international classification
of disease, or ICD for short.
A vendor can demonstrate
that they meet this criteria
by showing the EA chart can
store test ICD test codes and
supplement them with problem status and
date diagnosed.
The testing would include the asking
the vendor change your problem status.
For example, from active to resolved and
demonstrating that
this change is posted and displayed in
appropriate places throughout their EHR.